something we didn't necessarily expect
coming out of Fox News in the wake of
the Tucker firing
Tucker gets canned
sends shockwaves throughout media and
the political establishment but he
doesn't totally get canned he's just
taken off the air he's still being paid
by Fox News
so he can't speak on camera
he's still under contract
and he could remain under contract until
just after the 2024 election
keep that keep that pesky conservative
quiet just through Joe Biden's re-elect
and then we can let him talk again
since Tucker was fired there have been
leaks of supposedly damning footage
of Tucker Carlson
being likable that was the funniest part
of the leaks the Tucker leaks is that
they were intended to destroy Tucker's
reputation because they would catch him
making jokes in the makeup chair
they'd catch him sending texts to
colleagues and the idea was we're going
to find out Tucker he's evil sexist
racist supremacist
and then when you read them you think oh
this guy one this guy's very funny and
likable his staff obviously loves him
he's very normal a humble
it's an unusual fact for people in the
media and then you read his text and you
think he's also very thoughtful he's
he's paying attention to the way that
media wore people's minds and he's got
some trepidations about that and so that
completely backfired
everyone seemed to assume that the leaks
were coming from Fox
who has this footage this footage is
going up to a satellite and it's going
over to Fox so unless Tucker is leaking
it which I that would be some 17 DHS I
don't think that would happen then it
would have to be Fox right
Fox is saying no
Fox is insinuating that actually
Dominion the election company that sued
Fox over statements made by Tucker and
actually statements made more
provocatively by other Fox hosts
that Dominion
somehow got their hands on this footage
and they're the ones leaking it
so Fox sent a letter to Dominion
letters called on the company to
immediately investigate several leaks to
the media of redacted material that
Dominion obtained in the discovery
period of this defamation case
Fox News is asking Dominion to
investigate these leaks as quote
disclosure of these documents would
violate the protective order and the
agreement of the settlement agreed to
roughly three weeks ago Fox News has
given Dominion's legal counsel to look
at the inexcusable release of
confidential Discovery material and
report back to Fox by the close of
business on May 8 2023 what day is it
it's the ninth all right we haven't
heard anything about it yet we'll find
out so the question is
is it Dominion that's leaking this is it
this
election company that
many people have raised questions about
obviously you're not allowed to say boo
about Dominion right now or they'll
threaten to sue you for a billion
dollars but if Dominion
is the source of the leaks
that would seem to raise a lot of
questions about dominion and their good
faith behavior in our Democratic
Republic
or
is this just a faint by Fox News
is this just Fox
recognizing that they're getting a lot
of blowback for the Tucker firing
that the ratings crashed once Tucker was
was booted off the air and the audience
hasn't forgiven them yet and the
audience is blaming Fox for the leaks
and so is it a faint for Fox to say hey
some other guy stop leaking all that
stuff from Tucker I don't know
I don't know
what do I know I don't I've appeared on
Fox News many many times
I have no I've appeared on Tucker show a
number of times love Tucker
I don't really have any relationship
whatsoever to dominion and don't don't
care for them all that much but
all of that to say I don't exactly have
a horse in this race
but what degree of strategy and
deception is going on here
any degree
of deception whether it's just a simple
fact of fox wants to keep Tucker off the
air through 2024
whether it's Fox is trying to ruin
Tucker's reputation whether it's fox
wants to take Tucker off the air through
2024 but Dominion wants to ruin Tucker's
reputation Fox is coming ashy to defend
Tucker's reputation
at whatever
level of this we're talking about
it does raise a lot of questions about
what it is with Tucker Carlson that
some or many people want this guy to
shut up what is it what's because Tucker
is different
from the other hosts on cable news right
now go to
preparewithnolls.com I love that URL I
wish I had bought that myself years ago
prepare with knowles.com it's hard to
trust anything or anyone these days if
you've been paying attention to current
events at all these past few years you
know that you need to be prepared for
anything there is no better place to
start than by having a supply of
emergency food on hand right now my
Patriot Supply is knocking 200 off their
popular three-month emergency food kit
go to prepare with knowles.com grab this
special deal before it ends your
three-month emergency food kit provides
over 2 000 calories each day for optimal
strength and energy and stressful
situations enjoy a wide variety of
breakfasts lunches dinners drinks and
snacks do not put off your preparation
any longer tomorrow may be too late you
just don't know especially when things
are going crazy in the political order
go to prepare with knowles.com save 200
on each kit that your family needs go to
prepare with Knowles dot com right now
that is
preparewithnolls.com right now go to
ramp.com
Knowles if you want to simplify your
business finances ramp could be a
complete game changer for your business
ramp is a corporate card and expense
management software designed to help you
save time and money with ramp you can
issue cards to every employee with
limits and restrictions and automate
expense reporting so you can stop
wasting time at the end of every month
ramps accounting software automatically
collects receipts and categorizes your
expenses in real time so you don't have
to the time that you will save each
month on employee expenses will allow
you to close your books eight times
faster businesses that use ramp save an
average of 3.5 percent within the first
year ramp is easy to use get started in
less than 15 minutes and whether you
have five employees or five thousand
right now you can get 250 off when you
go to join ramp just go to ramp.com
Knowles that is RAM
issued by Sutton Bank and Celtic Bank
members FDIC terms and conditions apply
Tucker
is by far the most conservative of the
other hosts with big audiences on cable
news
some shows on the right
will not invite certain people who are a
little too conservative for them onto
the air Tucker would
certain voices on the right or the
center right wouldn't raise questions or
question
now decades old
orthodoxies about foreign policy
about economic policy for that matter
all the old GOP talking points Tucker
did
so a lot of people want to get Tucker
Carlson I feel like I'm playing a game
of Clue we're trying to figure out who
killed Tucker Carlson tonight and who's
trying to kill his reputation and a lot
of people have a motive to do it
a lot of people had opportunity to do it
even GOP lawmakers reportedly
are happy that Tucker is gone
report just came out and it's always
Anonymous of course
but here's what one journalist wrote
according to one GOP lawmaker quote
Tucker being gone makes my life easier
with many things including Ukraine
though I think that somebody will own
that space in a couple weeks anyway
a lot of people I'm glad the heat's off
from Tucker Tucker man that guy would
hold the conservatives feet to the fire
as much if not more
of the time than he would do that to the
Democrats
right
he also when he had a cable news show
was the most popular Cable News host
ever not just in his time slot not just
this year of all time
what does that tell you what an
indictment is that of the GOP
that the most popular cable news figure
on the right
it was totally out of Step
with the GOP politicians
what does that tell you it tells you
that the Republican party and the
politicians and the political Elites
are operating
in a different world from the base there
is a major Chasm between the base
and the people who are supposed to
represent them you don't really see that
on the left
Joe Biden he's the establishment
moderate sort of democrat who's been in
the federal government pretty much
without break for 50 years
he's he's a moderate guy good old
moderate Scranton Joe it's those crazy
Fringe people like AOC and Richard
Levine and Sam Brinton and Rashida Talib
and all the they're the ones who were
backing crazy policies like not just
transgenderism but transiting the kids
right oh no Biden's backing that too
well it's just the crazy aocs who are
backing the green New Deal 90 trillion
dollar plans to totally upend our
economy oh no actually Biden has
endorsed major parts of the green New
Deal and actually passed them into law
through the quote-unquote inflation
reduction act that made inflation worse
that they immediately admitted was
actually a climate bill
that incorporated a lot of elements of
aoc's crazy Green New Deal on the left
the the base and the establishment are
pretty much in lockstep because even if
the establishment is is not as zealous
as the base
that establishment just goes along with
what the base wants
on the right that is not the case on the
right they'll have the right Wingers
sniping at the most conservative guys
very often and celebrating when they're
taken off the air
man that was one sizzling hot clip huh
if you want to get more of those clips
and long interviews and the yes or no
game and Face-Off and The Daily Show you
got to subscribe to the Michael Knowles
YouTube channel click it ring the bell
do the thing we'll catch you next time
[Music]
foreign